for the rest of this video segment I
thought I would go through a few of them
with you and we'll watch them together
so let's start with this one it's
actually a piece of art but I
immediately saw the technology involved
with getting those balls floating in the
air so it's relevant for us I think and
I think the video continues to engage us
I was really drawn to the color in this
particular attempt it's quite beautiful
in that sepia tone for me anyway okay so
now we see a hand that's interesting
they're making the video a little more
compelling by inserting a fourth ball
okay it's a good idea that you run the
video and change it after a few seconds
so look what's going on now they've cut
into a new video with colored balls
which is really quite beautiful and so
we're inserting yet another iteration of
the video after the first and I'm still
fascinated and want to look at all those
balls the same setup that was in the
previous video but this time colored and
we're at the very end now and there you
go I thought it'd be fun for you to just
take a look at this particular one the
question is whether or not this is
relevant to your own video making that's
your call so let's go to the next one
you're seeing a surface inside a piece
of equipment and we see drops of water
forming on the surface I gather the
researcher first tried to capture the
phenomenon with angles lighting this
there were too many reflections and
glare he mentioned to me so in the end
what you're seeing here is interestingly
a ring light it's concentric with the
lens and it's lighting the surface at a
perfectly perpendicular angle I remember
that he tried a lot and wound up with
this one and we're seeing that these
drops are coalescing and becoming larger
and that is in fact the point of the
science later when he sent it to me I
asked if he intended
to include in the frame the left side
wall of the apparatus for me it looked
kind of like an accident
and in fact his first response was that
he didn't intend to show the wall but
after thinking about it the edge is very
informational to scientists who
understand this kind of stuff because
the edge effects the motion of the drops
so for me I would have shown even more
of the edge great deal of attempts were
made in trying to make this video in the
end as I think it's a great job so
here's something that's considerably
different from what we've been seeing
before we're seeing a flattened
something-or-other become unflattering
you can guess that the battery is making
all this happened it's somewhat origami
like wouldn't you say and now he's
becoming even more of a something I
don't know what to call it it really it
really is a robot and so these
researchers are doing some pretty
fabulous stuff where they you start with
a flattened assemblage that becomes
something else and we did speed this up
a little bit so that's why you're seeing
some jumps there he goes kind of silly
but incredibly unique and very exciting
leaving a trail behind him by the way
and finally this last batch is a bit
beyond the course because these videos
were made with a high-speed camera but I
thought I'd get you excited about your
next steps in case your work will
benefit from high-speed photography the
point here is as we continue to suggest
is that the way you approach any kind of
videos should still be informed by what
we've been discussing for the past few
weeks on how to make your still image I
hope you agree about that